so clearly the world is changing social
media is here and everybody's so darn
scared you know what does that mean
I mean I really don't care what you call
it but clearly there are two-way
conversations going on in the internet
and brands are being built differently
and as we go into 2009 and beyond the
eyeballs are being stretched from what
was just you know radio or actually
those ears
you know newspapers and then television
for such a long time and then more
channels of television but now with the
Internet age so many people spending
more time on their computer than in
front of television the way brands are
going to be built is going to change
because we're the eyeballs go brands go
and what do these brands have in common
well what I think they have in common is
they have to realize that in 2009 and
Beyond they've got to look at the way
they build their brand and interact with
the people is like the difference
between giving a presentation and
working a room so what does that mean
these brands especially old-school
brands like Cracker Jacks
for example have spent years and years
and years understanding that they give
presentations right they buy big buy a
newspaper ad or magazine ad they have a
presentation you consume it you see it
it was a presentation that's where the
conversation ended you didn't talk to
Cracker Jack himself he didn't talk to
you know the Cinnamon Toast Crunch dude
didn't talk to them it may told you
something you absorbed the whether you
liked it or not
that's how you made your decision well
just like if it may confer install
somebody gives a presentation and then
goes out backstage and is out in the
limo and off to the races you know you
loved it it was a great concert maybe a
great presentation but there was no
conversation after in my opinion using
things like Twitter and Facebook and
things like Ustream and YouTube and
things like viddler and Vimeo and things
like StumbleUpon and Digg and all and
then blogs and all these tools and
websites and all the things that are
about to come in the future is like
working a room unlike giving a
presentation working a room is going in
and having many conversations with lots
of different people if it's a huge room
lots of many different conversations oh
I think your logo sucks well I think
your logo is awesome well I didn't like
that flavor oh I love that flavor and
gathering all that information and the
quicker brands like this understand that
they need to start working the room
instead of giving presentations
they're gonna be the ones that win and
now the problem is there's so many CEOs
and CMOS and chief marketing this and
that Mis in these companies don't really
don't care about you know General Mills
or they don't really care about Nabisco
don't worry about their stock price they
were about their cash out and they
worried where they're moving on to in
three years and that's why a lot of big
brands are gonna lose but these small
nimble companies are going to be
creating you know marketers people come
together from big companies they're
gonna be the ones that create the next
red bull or the next vitaminwater and
the reason they're gonna be able to do
that is because they're gonna network
and work social media and here's what's
sexy compared to red bull and
vitaminwater the cost of the next big
brands and beverage and in chips and
ketchup their cost is just their time
they just have to care enough to work
the room